[Musique]
c'est joli ce tableau ah ouais c'est
quelqu'un qui s'appelle l'autre ben
voila
je me l'enlever non non non pas du tout
au contraire c'est très bien
bonjour jean tirole bonjour et merci
beaucoup de nous accorder cet entretien
alors nous allons parler de la dette de
ces montagnes de dettes qui s'accumulent
pour les états et de la façon au fond la
plus probable de les rembourser qui va
payer la facture c'est une question qui
préoccupe beaucoup les français mais
avant cela je m'adresse à l'économiste
que vous êtes est ce que vous êtes très
inquiet 8% de récession c'est colossal
peut-être que ce sera plus est ce qu'on
arrive à ce stade de la crise a mesuré
les choses jusqu où l'économie peut
s'effondrer oui il faut déjà être assez
abl parce qu'on ne connaît pas la nature
de ce virus est encore pas ce type de
crise économique c'est entièrement
nouveau donc ça pose la question de
combien de temps ça va durer donc pour
l'instant c'est qu'à peu près 6 % des
français qui ont été immunisés entre
guillemets parce qu on est pas en trop
sur contre le coréen virer ces questions
on va voir sans doute une deuxième puis
une troisième vague et donc le
confinement sympa de moi ça va beaucoup
puisque deux mois ayant une perte
économique considérable et quand on dit
oui pour cent ça suppose toujours que
d'abord on n'a pas perdu trop
d'activités panse ses plaies de
confinement mais aussi qu'elle n'y aura
pas de deuxième vague donc enfin c'est
vraiment une vision très optimiste des
choses j'espère qu'elle est juste mais
évidemment parce que ça serait bien
qu'on puisse trouver un médicament
miracle voir avec ça mais il faut pas
l'attendre immédiatement que je pense
que ça va coûter très cher à la
collectivité
qu'est ce qui va se passer il faut
s'attendre à des vagues de licenciements
à des vagues de faillite à des vagues de
chômage 1 millions peut-être plus de
chômeurs il y en avait huit cent mille
en 2008 alors ça va être compliqué pour
l'instant l'état en france comme
ailleurs après est ce qu'ils devaient
faire le protéger l'emploi et des
mesures de soutien à l'emploi mais ces
choses qui sont utiles mais un peu
artificielle parce que qu'est ce qui va
se passer quand les entreprises vont se
remettre au travail bien sûr elle est
surendetté alors pour l'instant il faut
comprendre que des ménages n'ont
pratiquement rien payer la facture celle
appelée ménages ont gardé leurs
poubelles pouvoir d'achat sans problème
et environ 160 % du coût a été payée par
l'état et un tiers par les entreprises
donc malgré les mesures de soutien donc
les entreprises vont se retrouver avec
une perte ça manque à gagner et une
partie est un recours des charges allant
pêcher enfle sociales et les impôts
c'est quelque chose qui va être payé par
exemple aux prises à terme et puis
l'état c'est nous aussi on viendra
assurer que la dette publique donc ça
pose après nos entreprises qui vont être
avant des preuves de son habilité je
pense que les problèmes de liquidités
ont été plus ou moins à ranger sur le
court terme a été rangé grâce à des
garanties de prêts des records de charge
d'une chose comme ça mais par contre
quand les choses vont revenir à la
normale va il y aura pas mal
d'entreprises qui vont être sur le
carreau ce qui veut dire qu'ils qui fait
souffrir le plus dangereux est
évidemment ce sont les pme qui
sont traditionnellement plus fragiles
financièrement et puis elle a des
entreprises des secteurs qui sont
fragiles donc évidemment le transport la
restauration les spectacles tous ces
secteurs qui aujourd'hui et même demain
auront du mal à avoir des
utilisateurs et donc ces secteurs sont
en difficultés des entreprises les plus
fragiles risque finalement de faire
faillite ou au minimum de ne plus
embaucher donc effectivement ça va pour
cela crée un problème d'emploi alors
pour soutenir l'économie l'état creuse
sa dette l'endettement de la france va
s'élever à 120 % du pib c'est du jamais
vu 9 % pour les déficits d'abord est ce
que c'est si grave il ya des économistes
qui vous disent au fond circulez ya rien
à voir les taux d'intérêt sont très bas
on peut emprunter ne nous gênons pas et
puis on remboursera plus tard sur des
dizaines et des dizaines d'années alors
tout d'abord il est normal que les
déficits publics se creusent très belle
pareil c'est tout à fait normal il faut
des mesures de soutien et donc pas de
problème un dossier pour l'âme
effectivement c'est qu'est ce qui va se
passer après alors les économistes qui
disent c'est pas grave ce sont les taux
intéressants sont très faibles un point
qui est juste c'est à dire que si les
taux d'intérêt sont égaux à zéro ça veut
dire qu'on peut continuer à s'endetter
et finalement ne jamais repayer à cette
dette tant que les taux d'intérêt
restent à 0 mais ça il ya deux paris
derrière ça y est de paris d'abord c'est
que les taux d'intérêt vont pas remonter
donc si on parle je suis assez confiant
à court terme dans les quatre cinq
prochaines années et taux d'intérêt vont
pas remonter parce que in fine et on va
garder les taux d'intérêt bas des
banques centrales on le ferait un etc
mais ici on parle d'une dette à 50 ans
on peut pas parier que pendant 50 ans et
tout l'intérêt pour pas remonter l'autre
chose qui m'inquiète un peu plus c'est
la spéculation entre les devises cirque
on l'a bien vu avec l'italie récemment
dès que l'europe fait semblant de ne pas
toujours soutenir à 100% jusqu'à 99%
l'italie les les taux d'intérêt
commencent pour l'italie commencent à
remonter avec des sprays par rapport à
l'allemagne qui sont importants les
autres hedge précis ce sont les écarts
de taux d'intérêt et le taux d'intérêt
auquel l'italie emprunter deux intérêts
auxquels l'allemagne emprunte donc il
peut y avoir même dans cette période des
attaques des attaques sur les états sur
les dettes d'états des attaques
spéculatives absolument année on vous
l'a vu avec la grèce avance et les taux
d'intérêt fixes étaient extrêmement
faibles parfois même négatif et ça
n'empêche pas qu'il y avait des attaques
sur la grèce ou à aujourd'hui des débuts
de la taxe en italie et donc la gaffe
bien fait le mal qui un peu vicieux un
cercle vicieux là parce que ça veut dire
que si on empruntait les taux d'intérêt
élevés
il ya plus à rembourser évidemment au
point de vue le chercheur la tête ça
veut dire plus d'austérité en mais et ça
veut dire que ça devient de plus en plus
difficile pour les populations de
souvenirs cela d'où il ya un risque
effectivement que le pays fasse défaut
sur sa dette cette option là monsieur
pérol elle est exclue pour la france on
ne peut pas faire défaut ce serait trop
risqué c'est risqué c'est vrai c'est
très risqué parce que quand on fait
défaut ça veut dire qu'il ya perte de
confiance dans le pays scénario donc
hautement improbable en ce qui concerne
la france ce qui se passe c'est que dans
ce cas notre l'austérité arrive
immédiatement puisqu'on doit équilibrer
son budget et imaginez aujourd'hui qu'on
voit avec les habitués à ça serait ça
serait catastrophique
donc c'est très très difficile deuxième
scénario qui semble très compliquée à
mettre en oeuvre à l'heure où nous
parlons la mutualisation des dettes au
niveau européen les fameux corona bonze
expliquez-nous de quoi il s'agit et au
fond quelle est la probabilité qu'ils
puissent au fond à avoir lieu alors les
corps en avant c'est une mutualisation
de la dette c'est dire que
si l'italie fait défaut sur cette dette
c'est à l'allemagne et la france l'autre
pays de payer donc c'est une certaine
forme de solidarité
et cette solidarité d'une façon sur la
façon et il ya peu un paradoxe c'est
dire que aujourd'hui l'italie n'est pas
du tout responsable des cures en avance
et donc ça veut dire que on devrait être
totalement solidaire écrit-elle et c'est
justement un moment où devrait être
totalement solidaire avec l'italie
complice de ne pas l'être parce que
effectivement dans des inquiétudes sur
la solvabilité de vitesse l'italie fait
défaut dans ce cas là c'est à
l'allemagne la france au pays de payer
et ça c'est un gars et un coup donc le
gars c'est effectivement c'est que ça
calme un petit peu la spéculation contre
l'italie
l'inconvénient c'est que ça va trop loin
quand j'entraîne une spéculation entre
la zone euro toute entière dire que
l'allemagne elle a très peu de dates
environ 60% donc elle peut payer mais
elle peut payer pour quoi pour elle même
à coup sûr mais est ce qu'elle peut
payer pour l'italie et a fortiori pour
l'espagne et la france ça paraît
hautement improbable
vous comprenez vous d'un point de vue
économique ce manque de solidarité en
tant quel citoyen de l'europe du sud je
souhaiterais décor en avant c'est
évidemment parce que c'est dans votre
intérêt
c'est moins dans l'intérêt de l'europe
et l'aurait on a laissé jouer cette
fracture entre l'europe du nord et
l'europe du sud est maintenant qu'un
tram va payer de manière après on peut à
la faire beaucoup par la bce c'est
peut-être le scénario le plus probable
l'action de la banque centrale
européenne la monétisation de la dette
expliquait nous là encore on voit qu'en
ce moment la banque centrale européenne
dirigée par christine lagarde rachète de
la dette aux différents états de la zone
euro et allège de fait leur dette
comment est ce possible or ce que fait
la bcc de racheter de la dette des états
ou pas aussi les banques donc on rachète
disons de la tête italienne donc ça
permet à l'italie finalement d'émettre
de la dette puisque les gens qui
achètent 16h05 après elle peut être
utilisée est fragile et par la banque
centrale donc sans
110,40 d'intervenir et donc ça permet à
l'italie de continuer à se refinancer or
il n'ya pas de miracle cette dette reste
sur les bilans à c'est pas elle
disparaît pas tout d'un coup comme ça
pourquoi c'est la meilleure solution
selon vous messieurs peut pas faire
faillite dans quelques jours et mettre
des liquidités
par contre ce qui peut se passer c'est
que il ya de l'inflation cirque elle l
aimait beaucoup de liquidités donc ça
veut dire que les agents économiques que
ce soit les banques ou les états ou plus
d'argent et comme ils ont plus d'argent
1 ils peuvent dépenser plus donc s'ils
peuvent dépenser plus alors qu'une offre
qui est qui est toujours la même ça veut
dire que ça va se traduire par
l'inflation ces mauvais l'inflation dans
cette période on n'a pas besoin
justement d'un petit peu d'inflation
pour d'une certaine façon
rembourser ou en tout cas à alléger le
poids de la dette oui tout à fait sûr
que l'inflation est le poids de la dette
donc s'il ya une inflation de 2 3 4 5 %
je dirais c'est pas la fin du monde a
les mêmes tant mieux ça laissera un peu
les poids des dettes
si en retour un système où l'inflation
est de 10 15 20 % ou plus c'est vraiment
dommage parce qu'on a on a mis trente
ans à vaincre cette inflation on a
réussi enfin l'accord l'inflation et
donc avoir de nouveau une impression
très froid ça serait dommage il ya un
dernier scénario celui là est peut-être
le plus insoutenable dans la période
c'est au fond faire reposer le fardeau
sur les contribuables faire un impôt
coronavirus ou même faire très vague et
je prends la france comme exemple les
français plus longtemps et plus se
serrer trop la ceinture cela pourrait
compromettre la relance économique et
donc il faut faire très attention ne pas
faire ça trop tôt ceci dit
landes on est immédiatement à l'esprit
la réforme des retraites cette année
trente ou quarante ans qu'on a des
rapports chaque année qu'ils disent en
gros à l'origine des retraites n'est pas
pérenne donc il faut trouver une
solution est-ce qu'on refusera de
d'améliorer les finances publiques parce
qu'il ne finisse à voir en quoi proposer
sur les finances publiques au moment où
ses finances publiques sont très
détériorée dans je pense que c'est une
décision politique mais il faut bien
réfléchir aux conséquences de cette
décision continuer les réformes à dans
lesquels précisément valérie force et
valérie formelle elle s'impose s'impose
clairement ses actes il va falloir
assurer la paix et la pérennité de
l'état providence mais qui n'est pas
assuré parce que là avec la dette qui
augmente
avec des déficits publics importants on
risque de se retrouver dans une
situation où on sera obligé de sacrifier
une patte l'état providence et et je ne
le veux pas et je pense que la très
grande majorité les français ne veulent
pas donc il va falloir trouver des
économies à l'heure où qu'est-ce qu'on
fait précisément où trouve-t-on les
économies je pense qu'il faut réfléchir
à la notion d'hostilités on s'aperçoit
aujourd'hui que l'allemagne auster un
truc entre guillemets à quatre fois plus
de places
dans les unités de soins sont intensifs
qu'elles dépensent beaucoup plus pour
soutenir l'activité que tout autre pays
européen parce qu'évidemment avait fait
des économies avant si on ne suit pas
l'allemagne dans les réformes on risque
de déclassement du français en lice ou
intégration et je dirais de façon plus
générale il faut investir à venir dire
que notre sensation c'est la
consommation et on néglige l'avenir
c'est qu'on néglige le climat on néglige
à l'éducation
france est catastrophique dans les
classements internationaux
on néglige l'université en néglige un
peu de tout ce qui va préparer l'avenir
en france c'est une dernière question
dans cette période il ya les pessimistes
qui parient sur des convulsions sociales
liées à la crise économique qui va être
difficile et puis j'ai les optimistes
qui eux rêvent d'une forme de nouvel
humanisme cette solidarité sur des biens
publics comme la santé ou est-ce qu'on
vous arrange jean tirole à moi je suis
je suis resté entre les deux mais
faudrait qu'on arrive à le changer de
société manor penser qu'on va voir un
grand soir est que tous les coups les
mentalités ont changé ça me paraît un
petit peu et alice irréaliste même si je
le souhaite merci jean tirole de nous
avoir fait partager vos analyses sur
cette crise sans précédent
merci merci beaucoup au revoir